we're talking about ex-con - I've played
a lot of it it's on consoles as of today
ps4 Xbox one released back in February I
think was twenty seven seventeen
there's a seven somewhere in there it's
my work today yeah correct yeah I'm not
gonna screw that up you're trying to
derail this already no it's a very good
game I liked it a lot I gave it a 9
109 like my favorite strategy games I've
ever played in terms of being a sequel I
think it's everything I wanted it took
the familiarity from the XCOM enemy
unknown and just kind of made the
strategy layer of base building and like
travel around the map and resource
management deeper and made the tactics
kind of even more varied with this many
more like options and nuance to it like
the storyline was just there to
facilitate the action but it was just
all around like a challenging game but I
loved playing every second of I know you
guys have not spent much time with it
but I just want we just sound in console
we want to talk about whether it's worth
returning to on consoles for people have
played it or it's worth just playing if
you have not played it yet well I don't
know Mike and I'm gonna chill the hell
out of this game because I know a lot of
people in our office haven't like gotten
a chance to play it yet yeah which is
unfortunate I think it's just because
again it just released on PC and enemy
Unknown was just on consoles right away
and I wish that wasn't the case but now
I'm hoping the console release will get
this game to where people's hands cuz
it's a very good game do you guys have
any interest in trying it now that's on
console um well my first question is
like how you know for XCOM game and many
other like just like strategy games you
want that like fluid Mouse work mm-hmm
like that's very important I feel like
for clicking for such a heavy HUD how
does that work is it mean is it a cursor
I mean I would imagine it's it's you
snap around right yeah you move like the
analog stick moves it through the tiles
and then the line of like where the
soldier will move based on where you put
it so if you put it here it's gonna show
the line going around this crate and
around this one it's definitely not as
fluid is just a mouse but it like to be
on consoles it feels very good you know
you can kind of a they're like hot buns
you press to go into overwatch you know
like to guard your teammates there are
certain buttons to use different
abilities the the button mappings feel
really natural the keyboard obviously
the same thing you could work those out
just as easily but like mouse cursor the
more you play with the analog sticks the
less you kind of notice it's not the
ideal way to play it but it looks just
as good as on ps4 Xbox one from what I
know
there you go you can see how it's
wrapping around objects and you know
like you get two turns most characters
unless they have special abilities and
everything but it feels really good it's
it's fast it's not it doesn't feel
cumbersome when you're trying to like
plan out your moves but it it has made
the transition well in terms of the
interface from in my experience what's
the deal what's your hunch why did this
take so long I don't know they did they
delayed it what was it like last earlier
this month or last month they were
originally gonna release it yeah but I
mean even just then like months removed
from the PC version when enemy Unknown
right because they have been talking for
like a year before it released on PC
that it's like it's developed it's
developed for PC and a lot of people
thought that man it's only come to PC
and but then like you start looking at
it they're like no I was just saying
they developed it from the ground up for
PC they never said they're working on
like port or whatever bring it over to
consoles I don't know you're like the
tech guy why would it be wood that could
attack play into that I don't know what
tools they're using to make these games
but I mean the architecture and the new
consoles is very similar to what most
people and most developers developed for
on PC yeah so I guess that's why I'm
slightly confused why it took so long
and I kind of feel bad that it took so
long and the slew of new releases this
might actually get lost and it does
sound like such a great game I mean you
loving like Final Fantasy Tactics the
very different themes when I tell you
like in terms of the kind of like the
combat attacks I think you'd love this
game I think I would too and I think it
come into console will make it easier
for me to play just because it's PC
gaming at home this isn't as simple for
me as it is in the office and when I'm
here a lot of other stuff going on so I
want to play it like yeah well I mean
one of the things people should know
because yes it's a nine but but what
sort of problems is the game maybe have
not to paint it in a negative light but
yeah like what's the full story some
technical issues have like migrated from
PC that were there I haven't played PC
in a while I don't know if they're still
present a lot of times you'll start a
turn and then you'll like initiate an
attack it'll zoom in into the action
camera and you'll hear the action going
on but the character will be frozen in
place for like sometimes up to ten
seconds and it's nothing game breaking
but every once in a while it test your
patience
well sometimes like enemies will be able
to shoot through walls they should not
be able to shoot through and like I've
know this game well enough to know that
they don't have this upgrade or they
don't that alien can't do that that
happens every once in a while so that's
one of my
initial complaints on PC is every once
in a while like not enough to hinder the
overall experience but sometimes the
enemies will ignore the rules that you
have to abide by which like the odds are
stacked against you in this game that's
the whole point you're rising up against
this like overpowered alien occupation
force and you're like this squad of
rebel fighters but in general none of
these technical issues impacted the game
on PC from back in the day again I don't
know if they have address time but even
on console like I experienced a few of
them in the few hours I played just to
double-check that consoles work well
yeah
but yet they I in terms of maybe that
was a problem they had bring into
consoles if they did like fully port it
maybe they had more a month ago that
they had to kind of fix sure I have no
idea
is there any incentive for someone on PC
who is a huge fan of XCOM to come back
to a console so that's like you know
they have an audience it just seems like
a missed I think Peter kind of said it
like a missed opportunity to like have
these come out more succinct or like
more you know in a similar deadline if
you if you just want an excuse if you
like like if you have it on PC now
there's not much reason because it comes
with the DLC which PC obviously already
has PC also has mods which I was showing
you I got like Star Wars mod you can
make the guys look like Boba Fett you
can get the halo guns which actually
have different stats they're not just
skins like that's why DLC kind of became
a little less relevant with us be game
because the mod support was out from the
beginning so people could make really
cool stuff but like alien hunters an
turkeys children and there's one more
than forgetting our present on the
console release so if you already played
it on PC if you already own it not much
incentive to come back unless you're
like me and just like need an excuse to
play it again for a little bit if you
don't have it on PC and you like it if
your console player obviously go buy
this game it's well worth the $60 or of
the full packages with the DLC and
everything and I highly encourage it
when did the last DLC come out because
it sounds like that might be the thing
that they were just taken care of before
I fit was I think was alien hunters and
an turkeys children and then there might
be one more but it was about two months
ago I think and that was the one where
it was kind of like that you made them
look like Mad Max characters kind of it
was like character customization stuff
but it was maybe that was what they were
tooling for to make sure they got all
the DLC knows
but that could be yeah I mean that's how
a lot development studio is working I
like Bethesda when they're working on
from what I understand but there's a lot
of times they'll have they'll keep their
like fallout 3 team on until DLCs done
and then migrate them over fallout 4
team until at the SC's done then bring
them over to you know whatever game
they're working on next I don't know I
don't want to sound like I do but yeah I
have no idea it is kind of a shame that
it's coming out right now when like you
have I don't know gears forwards on the
way
FIFO just came out those crowds don't
really overlap but then you have
battlefield 1 titanfall 2 Call of Duty
Dishonored 2 watchdogs to watch dogs to
mafia 3 is mafia 3 is the next big one I
think yeah yeah I think we're doing like
a section on the next episode or so down
there like a favorite holiday SIF to
write save six same day as battlefield
one October 21st
yeah still no it's lieu of games yeah
totally yeah so XCOM 2 is on console now
ps4 Xbox one who's on PC back in
February but if you haven't played it on
PC and if you want to get like the whole
package with all the DLCs I highly
recommend it go check out our review on
GameSpot gave it a 9 out of 10 that is
XCOM 2